parce que tu fais c'est du passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les trophées riposte et chérie comme
tous les soirs a remis les trophées et
on va passer aux trophées du candidat de
télé réalité qui dit une grosse connerie
mais qui ne s'en rend même pas compte et
les nommés sont regardés aurélie dans
les princes et des princesses de l'amour
mais devrait tendre le centre se cherche
et je sens que je suis pas sorti de la
sttr jean sarrailh friendstream
il compte accrochez-vous parce que la
chaleur tête de beaucoup beaucoup groupe
beaucoup plus heureuse là mais c'est toi
qui nous rassure non bassila la
sécheresse vivian dans la villa des
coeurs brisés
c'est peut-être un mélange entre
l'amitié l'amour la fraternité je suis
pas méchant je laime vraiment c'est un
amour incommensurable
[Applaudissements]
apprenez d'accord égale le trophée le
trophée du siècle il n'a pas tout
compris à la vie
je sais que vous adorez les trophées des
postes regarder le trophée du chien qui
n'a pas tout compris la ville est nommé
son
[Musique]
le chien qui nage alors qu'il n'y a pas
d'eau le chien qui a pris son poste
pour un coussin
[Musique]
et le chien qui a confondu yoga et kama
sutra
[Musique]
la 3d active
déçu mais on est 3e catégorie le trophée
du candidat qui nous a fait le plus rire
regardez les nommés sont elisabeth dans
les 12 coups de midi
feliz avait petit je disais vous bien
jouer prendre le cul de pantin allison
dans tout le monde veut prendre sa place
vous cherchez quoi hop un homme j'ai pas
envie d les suivantes 1 avant pascal
dans les douze coups de midi
tu crois que je vais faire un l'acteur
principal
vous me portez merci pascal
j'adore
pour pascal saeyvoet pascal elle est
formidable
est ce que je quitte les cherry dans un
instant rester avec nous car j'ai un
truc à vous dire vous maxime kenny a oui
un truc en remportant le trophée du
poste du petit malaise
regardez les nommés sont
françoise dans personne n'y avait pensé
ça va françoise oui vous étiez stressé
en première manche un petit peu parce
que c'était mal parti mais bon vous
amuser quand même un tout petit peu à
tout petit peu ça fait mal laurent
romejko temps des chiffres et des
lettres
vous pratiquez un sport je ne sais pas
du tout de quoi il s'agit j'ai une
petite idée le paddle tennis ah oui pas
de le tennis tu seras alors c'est un
mélange de squash et de tennis j'ai eu
peur du gouffre je veux tennis / du
paddle il sait qu'on a du mal à faire du
coup dessus donc un animateur de soirée
jt de tf1 et ses pompiers ils ont bien
mangé bien bu dans le reste est menée en
scott de leur gourou de la coupe vous
voir comme nous on a vu tout à l'heure
le ciel rougeoyant la peine rougeoyantes
ce sont des pompiers m'ont crié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'abattoir le meilleur là vous le dis
c'est quoi deux promesses qu'on soit le
3e diable et moi j'ai envie de revoir
romejko je sais pas pour vous mais si ou
parce que regardez bien les gens c'est
fou quand même regarder je ne sais pas
du tout de quoi il s'agit j'ai une
petite idée le paddle tennis ah oui pas
de tennis sera alors ça mélange de
squash et de tennis j'ai eu peur à un
coup franc joué au tennis sur du paddle
il a servi au dessus donc
[Applaudissements]